naja also solltest anders mehr so mit
problem oder sie die auf dem acker wenn
welpen durchfall amt und hat uns ohne
farbe sowie das auch aus wie ein
kindergeburtstag fisch ja ich habe eben
so wenige kindergeburtstage als kind war
ich nie eingeladen wurde und ich möchte
das jetzt mit ihm herum lohnt sollte ich
weiß es nicht danke dass ihr das nicht
sofort merken wir machen heute freak
shake shake sind doch alles zusammen
kippe
und dann hoffentlich schmeckt ok müssen
wir das danach selber essen oder können
wir das verschenken wir können das
verschenken der wird aber wahrscheinlich
werden sie niemand finden der sich so
wenig respektiert dann würde doch essen
blick das nennt man auch diabetes in
zwei schritten machen trinken fertig ok
stört es mich dass sie manchmal auf ihr
äußeres reduziert werden wo passiert
denn sowas ja jetzt zum beispiel was ist
denn ihr beauty geheimnis vielen dank
für das kompliment nehmen werden wir
irgendwann nochmal über politik und sie
dürfen die ganze zeit über politik üben
interessant gerade das ganze system so
aufgeschaukelt haben während der mixa
anwalt für sich gehört haben viele
verzweifelte leute wählen die linke ist
es weil die leute in ihnen hoffnung
finden oder weil sie denken jetzt auch
egal also die hälfte wird uns immer aus
überzeugung für unseren programmen die
anderen wählen uns aus empörung über die
anderen parteien
ich glaube nicht mehr an gelernt wir
noch mehr als ein buch finde ich meinen
auch immer total lecker aber in der tat
sehr viele und welche ausgeht und freaks
wir haben hier nicht technischer sondern
freaks ich komme ja auch zu schwach
ich hörte davon ist ja wie ein
klassentreffen heute eine schweizerin
trifft eine von der linken an zwei
verschiedene klassen treffen
[Musik]
bis spätestens jetzt trinken wir
niemanden mehr der das noch trinken will
wie können wir beide systeme sind sie
die demokratie bewirbt sich
ich will die ddr nicht wiederhaben
allgemeine ich hatte eine
alleinherrschaft der linken nicht dafür
kenne ich die zu gut aber das wäre ich
bei keiner partei dafür
ich hatte eine sehr schöne kindheit dank
meiner eltern aber die ddr will ich
nicht wieder haben das einzige was eine
ddr besser was mich ist das alles echt
aber also so kommen sieht man noch nicht
sagen dass das in der ddr in besser kopf
spätestens mit der klimakrise und mit
dem migrationsdruck wird doch deutlich
dass die adressen gute idee dass die
brauchen wir alle probleme nicht
irgendwie nicht um die an der
landesgrenze halt machen sondern die
kommen halt alle an und insofern es
kommt halt im das zurück was man auch an
unterdrückung und an waffenexporten und
so weiter in die welt exportiert kommt
irgendwann zurück vielleicht noch ein
boden aber das hält doch jetzt nicht und
videospielen internet vielleicht noch so
dekorieren
war das jetzt das internet
ich glaube das ist das symbol dass wenn
wenn wenn man über bereits zu groß wird
dann 2000 anders
jetzt wollen wir natürlich noch ein
bisschen gemerkt ihre version von diesem
free trade machen
ich dachte wir machen für sie eine ddr
version also einfach alles rein und
gucken ob es schmeckt zwar
wahrscheinlich in jeder ddr cocktailbar
so wir haben hier gurken
sie können ja mit dem gurken wasser aus
basis anfang und dann die brocken er für
deko zwecken verwenden
was können sie den leuten für gründe
geben warum lieblings wählen sollen
wenn du in der partei haben
[Musik]
schweinefleisch natürlich nicht
vergessen unsere eigenen saft durch den
vegetarierin was selten zur froh das
sagen zu können
aber es ist schön rosa ein bisschen die
camping urlaub das riecht eigentlich wie
eine werbung für den islam
sie werden ja seit drei jahren gar nicht
mehr vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
das war die sich jetzt auch nicht mehr
für sie interessieren wieso auch nicht
es ist ein erfolg war bodo ramelow hat
sich so erfolgreich dagegen zur wehr
gesetzt was die in klein beigeben musste
bei der wirtschaftskrise wie so waren
sie da nicht viel aggressiver da hatten
sie einfach ganz groß propaganda machen
müssen und sagen ja das stimmt das sind
alles passte
das haben wir gemacht gab nur so wenig
fernsehen länder die darüber berichtet
haben ja das muss einer zensur in der
schweiz liegen die wollten ist
vielleicht nicht so in unsere
kapitalismus prävention filter drüber
wenn lauter gegen arm nächste mal ein
bisschen langweilig jetzt nur so wollte
ich das jetzt aber das eis drauf machen
ich dachte ich noch einmal so hier rum
und dann haben wir so ein halter für das
eisen das reicht dann auch zufrieden mit
dem krieg sprechen eigentlich ein gutes
hochdeutsch für jemanden aus dresden
hält trainiert ich finde es fast nicht
irritieren
so jetzt auch mal verlärmung und machen
ein bisschen golden
naja so soll das anders also wird konsum
oder sieht ihr aussehen mokka sieht er
so also wenn welpen durch verrat und
hatte so eine farbe
[Applaus]
wir können ja noch mal ist ein ernstes
thema reden gerne
müsst ihr auch viel im netz unterwegs
oder wie geht die eigentliche held von
mara so gar nicht mehr hinschauen ob die
leute das feiern oder nicht ob du so
damit attackiert wird oder ich eine oder
kriegst du immer noch so kann die stones
ich würde mir machen kennedys tod
gestorben ist folglich strecken travel
channel sind ken disney will nämlich
sagen prost 2000 kalorien jetzt jemanden
der das dringend für uns oder das müssen
wir nicht selber machen
ich hoffe dass ich bin nicht so gut wie
sie glaube ich ich muss versuchen noch
selber machen guten appetit
ich dachte ich fang mal mit den
salzstangen an sich geschickter weise
ganz oben drauf ich würde immer kurzem
und auch ein stück kuchen
wenn man schon mal im westen geboren ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]